c'est bon c'est fini
un appareil photo des lampes de couleurs
ces ateliers light painting à elancourt
une activité dans le cadre de
l'exposition entre voir l'invisible en
bleu en verre ou en rouge on écrit et on
dessine avec la lumière
c'est une technique de photos qui permet
de saisir le mouvement de le mouvement
de lumière notamment avec des petites
lampes torches et ensuite d'autres
systèmes avec des led mais voilà donc de
saisir le mouvement lumineux avec un
appareil photo
ça permet de créer des formes des objets
comme emplie imprimé dans l'air on va
dire font un appareil photo qui est un
temps d'obturation qui est capable donc
de prendre une photo sur une période
assez longue
outre l'aspect ludique le light painting
simplifie la science l'activité mais en
pratique optique infiniment petit ou
encore trajet de la lumière des notions
complexes que les visiteurs test lumière
et appareils photos à l'appui
le light painting semble convaincre les
visiteurs
j'ai essayé d'écrire mon prénom j'ai
fait un coeur avec ma mère et
et j'ai fait les roues d'un vélo c'était
trop bien je pensais pas que ça existait
c'était super les enfants ont adoré
c'était très ludique on a pu participer
nous aussi à l'atelier de light painting
et voilà je pense qu'on repart avec des
bonnes idées pour faire des ateliers
avec les enfants
l'exposition entrevoir l'invisible se
tient à la commanderie des templiers
elle se termine le 1er juillet